das ist er der neue Kampfstiefel des
Bundesheeres er ersetzt ab sofort seinen
Vorgänger den handgenähten Bergschuh der
in verschiedenen Varianten seit 64
Jahren im Einsatz ist in den 1980er
Jahren wird der feldschuh 2 eingeführt
von Soldaten liebevoll auch zwarabog
genannt in den vergangenen 43 Jahren
erlebt auch er eine Reihe von
Modifikationen und
Anpassungen diese Woch werden die
ersten des neuen kampfstiefels an die
Truppe
übergeben ein sogenannter Meilenstein
für die heres bekleidungsanstalt die für
Bekleidung und Rüstung der Truppe
verantwortlich zeichnet denn die
Aufgaben der hba werden immer
vielfältiger und umfangreicher früher
haben die Soldaten eine Uniform bekommen
und alle haben gleich ausgeschaut s
jetzt mal jetzt macht man wirklich
waffengartung spezifisch wird die
richtige begleidung für die einzelne
waffengartung hergestellt die Idee für
den neuen Kampfstiefel liegt erstmals
2017 auf dem Schreibtisch von Jürgen
Marx dem schuhchefentwickler der hba er
erklärt was nach der ersten Idee alles
in die Gänge kommen musste mit unserer
Truppe erarbeiten wir ein technisches
Anforderungsprofil was braucht der
Soldat danach entwickeln wir hier in der
heresbegleidungshanstag gemeinsam mit
der Wirtschaft mit einem
Schuhproduzenten einen Schuh auf diesen
Anforderung die wir hier vorgegeben
haben technische Spezifikation wie
Lederstärke reisfestigkeit Futter
Wasseraufnahme wasserab Gabe
Rutschfestigkeit der Sohle Haltbarkeit
der Sohle Haltbarkeit des schubbandes
Reißfestigkeit des schubbandes all das
wird in eine technische Spezifikation
gegossen und das geht dann in eine
europaweite Ausschreibung und das wird
dann auch wieder einzeln bei uns geprüft
das Leder die Schuhbänder die so und
erst wenn all das erfüllt wird bekommt
die Firma den Auftrag diese Schuhe zu
fertigen und das nimmt dann rund 30.000
Arbeitsstunden in Anspruch denn in jedem
Schuh steckt rund 2 Stunden Handarbeit
der neue Kampfstiefel ist das was wir
als state of the art bezeichnen können
ob es Luft nach oben gibt werden wir in
der weiteren Entwicklung uns anschauen
aber es ist wirklich state of the art in
allem was da drinnen ist man sitzt von
außen gar nicht 150 Teile sind
verarbeitet in einem Paar Kampfstiefel
und ein paar braucht zwei Stunden
Handarbeit bis es gefertigt ist also das
sieht man dem nicht an Stiefel oder
Schuhe sind nach wie vor praktisch
Handarbeiten mit maschinenhilfe
sind mit der Hand gefertigt wir lassen
Schuhe fertigen und lassen die in einer
gewissen Größe machen das erste Modell
war 700 paar und die werden dann in die
Truppe ausgegeben damals 2018 an 10
Verbände die wir über ein Jahr lang
getestet haben von Frühjahr Sommer
Herbst und Winter weil wir müssen ca 50°
Temperatur abdecken Winter - 200° bis im
Sommer bis zu + 40° sind sogar 60° all
das müssen wir hier testen hält der
Schuh ist ja warm ist ja rutschfest wie
verhält das sich mit Schnee auf Stein
auf Moos auf Wiese das wollen wir alles
begleiten und so geht das Schritt für
Schritt wir begleiten die Truppe und
jetzt sind wir im Jahr 2023 wo dann der
Schuh auch produziert wird 15000 Bar
sind schon eingeliefert worden das
dauert auch eine Zeit bis die produziert
wird und jetzt sind wir stolz darauf
dass heute die ersten Schuhe an die
Truppe übergeben werden konnten neben
den neuen Kampfstiefeln wird in der hba
auch die unterschiedlichste Rüstung für
Soldatinnen und Soldaten je nach Bedarf
verarbeitet Rüstung und begleidung wird
immer wichtiger vor allem der
persönliche Schutz das betrifft jetzt da
nicht jetzt nur ballistischen Schutz
sondern das ist auch schutzverwitterung
wir gehen jetzt auch in die
Spezialisierungen hinein warmes Wetter
kaltes Wetter Spezialisierung im Bereich
der Waffengattungen und so weiter und
die Mission vorwärts hat hat natürlich
durch die Budgetierung durch die
Möglichkeit dass jetzt mehr Geld
vorhanden ist natürlich einen Schub an
Geschwindigkeit gebracht dieser
Geschwindigkeitsschub soll natürlich
allen zugute kommen be uns ist es egal
ob der grumdiener kadersoldat ist
Berufssoldat Offizier gener oder Rekrut
ist ja alle sollen dieselbe begkleidung
dieselbe Qualität an Bekleidung haben
die Mission vorwärts beginnt also
Schritt für Schritt zu greifen wichtig
dabei ist jetzt nicht nur auf Quantität
zu setzen sondern dabei auch die
Qualität nicht aus den Augen zu
verlieren und das gilt nicht nur für die
hba jedes Gerät se der Hubschrauber der
gelandet ist se dann auch der Ulan der
an die Truppe auf ausgeliefert wird oder
das neue Sturmgewehr all das zeigt dass
wir auf einem richtigen Weg sind mit
unserer Mission vorwärts der Aufbauplan
geht bis 2032 und darüber hinaus aber
die Budgets die beschlossen worden sind
beten eben genau die Möglichkeit das
österreichische bundesher zur modernen
Armee zu
[Musik]
machen